imagine a scenario where the big bang
happened twice imagine a scenario in
which it happened numerous maybe an
infinite number of times imagine a
scenario in which the Big Bang never
happened at all may sound crazy but all
these scenarios are possible when we say
big bang it's become so ingrained in
almost the zist the consciousness of of
the times that we believe it sort of
that we just take it for granted that it
happened recently due to evidence from
the James web Space Telescope The Big
Bang Theory has come under some scrutiny
some astronomers even have called into
question whether the Big Bang happened
or not was there a underlined italic
bold a big bag a singular big bag or
could it have happened more than once or
not at all I had a great time discussing
these topics and many many more with my
friends Paul Davies and Malik parik tune
in and find out more about what happened
at the earliest moments in our
universe's history welcome everyone to
tonight's Thinking Beyond um we have
today uh we're very happy to have um Dr
Brian keing as our speaker um Brian is a
is a Chancellor's distinguished
professor of physics at the University
of California in San Diego he's a public
speaker an inventor and an expert in the
study of the universe's oldest light the
cosmic micro microwave background or
CMV he's also a writer and the creator
of the podcast into the impossible as
well as the bestselling author of one of
Amazon editors uh best non-fiction books
of all time losing the Nobel
Prize U he'll be joined in conversation
today by Paul Davies most of you know
Paul but he's the director of the Beyond
Center for fundamental concepts in
science and also region professor at
Arizona State University his research
covers everything from quantum gravity
to cosmology to astrobiology and he's
the author of many books uh most
recently what's eating the universe and
other Cosmic questions
so without any further Ado I'm going to
pass it on to Brian uh who will um put
up his slides now well great thrilled to
be there remotely one of the few places
that can claim that they have uh maybe
not uh better weather than San Diego but
they have better sports teams so it is a
great thrill to be here uh back with my
friend uh Paul Davies who's been a many
Time guest on my podcast into the
impossible and unlike my classes and
probably Paul and Malik's classes we uh
allow only use of cell phones to take
some QR code pictures so if you're
watching on your computer you could take
out your phone and uh snap these three
or save them for later and that will
whisk you away to various uh Delicacies
for the mind that I will explain in just
a bit but tonight we're really going to
focus on three main questions uh very
brief run through of modern cosmology
what we know what we know we don't know
and the biggest mystery and the reason
for the very cleverly you know in my
mind designed title uh was whether or
not there was a single Big Bang that's
why the title of the talk is was there a
underline italic bold a big bang a
singular big bag or could it have
happened more than once or not at all
and lastly a topic near and dear to my
heart Paul's heart the Multiverse we'll
get into that and we'll cover some
topics along the way but first as I say
there's some homework we need you guys
to do some homework first so again take
out your phones if you have them or go
visit these websites and the reason is
there's something in it for you you will
win a meteorite if you have a.edu email
address uh I don't know if you can see
it I'm holding up one of these
meteorites which you can probably get at
ASU but uh these will uh be very
especially sent to you all who have
a.edu email address and that's on my
website bing.com if you don't you may
win a meteorite you may not and that's
at bing.com list um so I'll show these
again later but uh this is sort of the
only entry fee for the talk and that is
to subscribe and stay in touch with me
because you'll find out when great
guests and great appearances like Paul
and and others Sarah Walker has been a
guest multiple times and we'll have uh
keep you up to date with all the musings
around the so there you go there's
Sarah Walker's uh last year she gave a
wonderful presentation on her research
on to my audience that Paul gave one on
his book uh eating the universe and he's
also been here in person we go through
great effort to make uh to make these
videos fun and entertaining and we had
on H math professor math teacher Eugenia
Chang today we've had on Sabine hen
Felder and I've appeared with various
folks like Lex Friedman Joe Rogan many
others and it's a lot of fun and that's
on my YouTube channel so you can take
that QR code and you know go to my
YouTube channel Dr Brian ke So today
we're going to talk about cosmology and
I'd be missed if I did did not mention
some of the earliest cosmological models
occur in none other than the Bible where
the beginning of the Old Testament
starts with a cosmological claim it
doesn't start with some discussion about
what some nomadic tribe of of Hebrews
should eat and what they shouldn't eat
or you know what day is their weekend
beginning and so forth it actually
begins with the big benang or does it
and that's a question we will grapple
with tonight because to me
this is why I do what I do and the
interest level of the stakes of what
Paul and I and Malik and others get to
study is so phenomenal and so uh so
impressive to ourselves that we get to
actually make quantitative statements
about things that have been debated by
theologians philosophers astrologers and
and and the like for literally the dawn
of recorded human history and this takes
us back as well a couple of uh Millennia
after that previous citation this is
from The Book of the Dead of kemu O and
I know you're all familiar with that has
a very high H index and I um am quite
envious of it it goes back 3,000 years
they're depicting a sort of cyclical
Eternal universe or maybe a beginning of
the universe these are the nature of
reality is that people are fascinated
with origin stories after all the most
likely answer that I've gotten when I
ask somebody what's your favorite day on
the calendar is it's my birthday Day or
Christmas or it's New Year's what do
those all have in common they're all
anniversaries of a beginning so we're
fascinated by Beginnings because we're
not privy to what happened before and
the question that modern cosmologists in
both theoretical and experimental
formats such as myself I'm an
experimental cosmologist which doesn't
mean I build universes it means I build
instruments with my team and we use
those instruments including teammates
from ASU very important teammates I'll
talk about later showing you the
instruments that are potentially going
to make an impact on answering the
question of whether or not there was a
single big bag fast forward uh a
millennium and you come to the aristot
Alan model of the universe which
involved a fixed finite size universe
that existed unchanged and static for
all eternity and the only things that
moved were the things that they gave
names to and the word Planet like plane
like airplane the word plane and Planet
both have the same meaning there's
something that moves and so when you
name something you give it a distinction
that means it must be different from all
the other things which meant they
thought the universe is mostly static
except for the five things they could
see with their eye that were physically
seeming to move against the background
of the fixed
Stars fast forward another nearly two
Millennia and you come to similar
Notions of a static Universe where
matter is distributed uniformly and this
troubled Isaac good old Ike and and in
that he didn't understand that a
universe could be gravitationally
balanced because he knew it was unstable
when you had matter because matter is
universally attracted that's his law
after all the law of universal
gravitation and so this was a great
conundrum a tremendous mystery for
hundreds of years and in fact it wasn't
even solved by one of Newton's decid
bolts who called Newton the greatest
contributor uh to human civilization not
just to physics but Einstein called new
this Titanic intellect that changed and
altered the course of history and of
course we have maybe encountered the
notion that Einstein made some blunders
in his life including potentially the
insertion of a term called the
cosmological or the vacuum term which we
now know as dark energy and that term
would stabilize the universe against
gravitational collaps Einstein was
pretty bright but he realized later on
after Hubble showed him the Universe
wasn't static that things beyond the
planets were in motion expanding
diffusing making the universe more
tenuous more uh more more spread out
with each and every passing second which
ushered in the notion of the Big Bang
which came from none other than a
Belgian Catholic priest Nam George latum
and I had on one of the students on my
podcast Francis Hollen the pi of the Ice
Cube experiment at the South Pole
Antarctica I've spent a couple of months
of my life myself we we'll see a quick
tour over that in a minute the student
of uh of lra was Francis Francis hen and
Francis told me stories about him you
can find that on the on my YouTube
channel or in my podcast but L Matra
proposed a primeval origin to the
universe which called the Primeval Atom
which was a single atom with nuclear
density with an extent of something like
four times the diameter of the known
solar system in
1929 and and of course we kind of laugh
at that notion now but but what it
ushered in was an explanation for how
the galaxies could currently be moving
apart from each other with the
implication being they must have been
touching at some point in the past and
that point in the past in time at least
is given by the reciprocal of the Hubble
constant what we call the Hubble
constant and so one of the major goals
of cosmology since that time is to been
to measure the expansion rate of the
universe and how fast the galaxies are
moving apart from one another and that
has a bearing on how old the universe is
and the two leading explanations or the
um observations of the age of the
universe seem to differ in the age of
the universe by about a billion years
which sounds pretty big but it's nothing
compared to when I was a graduate
student when we beli the universe could
either be 10 billion years old or 20
billion years old we actually knew there
were objects in the universe older than
the 10 billion year number meaning that
there could be children older than their
parents at least on a cosmic scale so
this uh Primal Adam effectively this
model still holds to this very day and
there have been other pillars added to
it three other pillars I'll talk about
in very brief detail given the amount of
time I've been allocated by the
taskmasters in charge Paul and and
Jessica who I thank very much for
inviting me and those involve relics
fossils things left over from the origin
of the universe and those relics travel
through space and time just like Indiana
Jones would be seeking and they inv
involve either material objects like
these meteorites here that I give to you
if you're edu email address on my
website or they can be in the form of IM
IM uh non-massive or massless particles
like photons gravitational waves and
nearly massless objects like
neutrinos so the object is to understand
how did these things get to be where
they are how have they traveled through
space and time from the earliest moments
of the universe hey there fellow
voyagers into the impossible it is I
your Fearless host Professor Brian keing
well I can't say for sure how many times
the Big Bang happened or if it even
happened at all I can say for sure that
only 18% of you are actually subscribed
to my content and that's a tiny tiny
number I'd love to raise it up to the
level of your GPA close to 100% so
please make sure that you're subscribed
or following the podcast on audio
wherever you are if you are you'll do me
a great service and help me help you to
get the greatest guest possible on this
amazing amazing journey we call into the
impossible now back to the episode and
the cartoon that I showed in my first
book called losing the Nobel Prize is uh
depicted here and it it shows the
universe's Evolution from a big bang
scenario where the beginning of the
universe we can associate that the big
bang with a variety of different things
one of them could be the origin of time
itself in fact that was the notion that
Hawking held to himself that the origin
of time was what Big Bang properly was
and so his his famous statement was that
asking what happened before the Big Bang
was like asking what's north of the
North Pole there are answers to those
questions in certain cosmological
scenarios perhaps not one where the
universe begins its temporal Journey To
The Future at time equals zero but there
are other models that will'll explain
and describe and that cosmologists are
in the position of ruling out not we
don't prove things in experiment
cosmology my job is not to prove Malik
or or prove Paul right not at all our
job is to really probably Pro prove them
wrong most theories are wrong most
experiments are inconclusive and it's
very rare you get to do a conclusive
experiment that actually verifies or or
perhaps gives Credence to a theoretical
idea and that's of course uh a rare
experience in in in in science as a
whole so is the science subtle
absolutely not we don't know for sure or
if there was a single Big Bang whether
there were multiple Big Bangs whether
there are Big Bangs going on to this
very day uh or a host of other scenarios
that we'll describe very briefly and
then I'll elaborate on during the Q&A
session if people are interested this is
my office at UC San Diego and there was
a very brilliant gentleman who occupied
it before me his name was Jeff Burbage
and he and his titanically accomplished
uh wife Margaret Burbage really changed
observational astronomy and and did so
many amazing things it's really hard to
catalog them all but one of the things
that he held to to his dying day in 2010
and I know this for a fact because we
talk all the time and yes the the the
the office is still just and Paul can
attest to this is just as messy as back
then uh and the only difference I don't
smoke a cigar in the office uh or so um
told I not allowed to so the steady
state universe is very popular in cont
distinction and in contrast to the Big
Bang model in fact many people found it
anathema both scientifically that you
could have time emerging from a
non-temporal state could have matter
coming into existence where did that
Primeval Atom come from people wondered
about so they came up with rival
theories and these held sway for many
many years until the late 60s mid mid to
late 60s and so one of these was that
the Universe was not static perfectly
static we knew since the time of Hubble
that the Universe couldn't be perfectly
static but it could be modified to be
slowly if you like oscillating never
reaching a uh an infinite Singularity
like the Big Bang model presupposes but
nearly oscillating into an add of uh a
more or less dense State and we existed
at a state where the abundance of helium
is plotted uh at in a uh versus a scale
factor or graphed as in terms of scale
factor um as it oscillated into an out
of and they only required a tiny amount
of helium or hydrogen to be produced
every every thousand years so it
actually held sway that you could get an
expanding Universe by the insertion of
energy creation xmo of energy they
didn't describe how
that they they posited it and then they
said and they look for ways to to
confirm this using data at the time and
in fact it was the diant source of data
and the dominant Paradigm even up until
1965 when the cosmic micro background
was discovered so anyway the
measurements have gotten better and
better over time thanks to spacecraft
and groundbased instruments we now know
that the uh Universe uh is bathing us in
a black body suffusing us with photons
with an average temperature
corresponding to a black body at 2.7
Kelvin that's the most perfect black
body in existence you can't make a
better one on Earth you can only compare
it to the cosmic manaray
background the detectors that we've been
using have been progressing faster than
Moore's Law getting more and more
sensitive such that as um as as you know
Moore himself as Gordon Moore passed
away last year said you know if if cars
progress at the rate of Moore's Law back
in 1965 you could actually have a
Rolls-Royce that would be so cheap and
so such high quality that you wouldn't
even park it you would just throw it
away and yet our detectors in this
series of experiments have gotten and
more exquisitly sensitive faster than
Mo's law so we're actually doing uh
better than a Rolls-Royce that you throw
away I don't know what what the what the
better option would be for it but we
want to explore this central question
did the big bang happen once so the
answer is that
maybe it could have happened uh more
than once that when we say big bang it's
become so ingrain in almost the zist the
consciousness of of the times that we
believe that sort of that we just take
it for granted that it happened but we
don't know much about it in fact in that
seminal paper from 1965 the authors
never describe nor do they describe in
the companion paper by uh by Wilkinson
and and Bob dicki uh and and later with
my friend and recent interview guest uh
Bruce Partridge they never describe a
big bang the words Big Bang do not
appear in this paper and they don't
appear in the famous companion paper
where Bob dicki said they're scooped
nowhere does it appear in fact the only
thing it appear appeals to is a cyclic
Universe a denser Epoch that existed
prior to the current formation of the
nuclei so even the authors themselves
didn't believe that this proved the big
bag it still was possible for the CMB to
be a relic of just the latest Big Bang
on the Block and now there are other
alternate models that are just as as
popular as as the Quasi steady state
model and some ways that they fit the
data and so forth but they all are
missing something crucial which is
experimental evidence and that's where
me and my team and others come in so
there's a couple models we'll get into
them I'm told with Mal leak maybe later
uh one that I've I've interviewed sir
Roger many times in my podcast uh is
so-called a conformal cyclic cosmology
where featuring these aons where you
conformally scale the only things that
exist in the Deep future of our current
universe will be photons and they
experience no lapse of time and so there
are certain mathematical tricks that
Paul and Malik can probably explain
better than I can that allow you to
formly scale the origin of a current Eon
with the so- called crossover point that
leads to another one deep in the future
the laws of physics behave the same and
each one ends with a type of of of
conformal stretching uh and this is an
infinite number of effectively an
infinite number of big Banks there are
also models popularized by my friend
Paul steinhardt and Anna egis both of
been past guest Neil turo as well past
guest these are called bouncing or are
crunching models where you have a
universe that collapses and then expands
and that expansion can take on a number
of different characters it can be a
singularity it can actually collapse to
a singularity or it can bounce and still
maintain a classical space-time
structure at the so-called crossover
point or the origin of our current
univers or our current observable
universe and here's an animation from
Quantum magazine that I like it's shows
that you're going down to a to a
collapse it doesn't necessarily lead to
a singularity and that's very important
because as Malik will probably tell you
at Great length he's published a on this
uh we don't have a good theory of
quantum gravity that could describe the
behavior of SpaceTime at a so-called
Singularity we lack it at the core of
black holes we lack it in the
description of the early extremely early
universe so it may be true that it does
collapse to a singularity but we just
don't know because we can't actually
handle the physics at those scales we
don't have an underlying
unification of the standard modle of
particle physics I.E quantum mechanics
Quantum field Theory with general
relativity which is a classical Theory
so it's really fascinating and and to me
the many flowers that bloom also give
opportunity to sort of uh have full
employment for experimentalists like me
because my job again it's not to prove
you know Paul Davy's model correct or or
you know alen Guth or Andre Lind or Paul
steinard it's really to prove everybody
else wrong and see what remains when the
best of the data have been assessed what
remains is the most plausible
explanation uh although it's not it's
not maybe not satisfying to the level up
say a mathematical proof which is not
possible in the physical sciences we
lack a dictive that allows us to
determine what is mathematically
provable in physics because there's
always possibility for countering
examples that can't be proven I I'll
discuss then just a bit but I like this
image well I like everything that I made
right I'm kind of narcissistic that way
but I made this image and I and I I did
look into um uh some some do inspired
drawings I want to I asked DOI give me a
picture of the bunch dav's vacuum and it
gave me something that looks like the
top left panel here where there's a
vacuum state of the early Universe uh
when it's empty and has certain
symmetries which Paul I I can't you know
it's like me playing you know Dancing
Queen in front of ABA and my harmonica
uh I won't I refuse to do it I won't do
it but Paul will do it at some point
hopefully later and hopefully they'll
come here again uh for a discussion of
these very fascinating topics but in
Paul's conception there is a symmetrical
state of the universe that then
experiences like all Quantum Fields a
fluctuating uh network of perations
which grow under the influence of
curvature and gravity to then provide
Wells gravitational potential Wells into
which dark matter and then later
ordinary matter like hydrogen helium Etc
can agglomerate into and in this model
structure can form from a Quantum field
which is no corporeal no particulate
analog and it takes a long time for that
to happen uh many many uh decades and
Orders of magnitude but this is a
process which once kicked off cannot be
stuned and the question is how can we
appraise the veracity of this model
versus other models and so here's a
little checklist or scorecard here of
different models that each one predicts
or can predict a multiple multi- big
bang scenario the Quasi steady state
model actually doesn't have a big bang
so I should say uh it can have
alternatives to the singular Big Bang
hypothesis so in the Quasi city state
cosmology QSC there is no big bag uh and
the bouncing cosmological model there
may be an infinite a number of
oscillatory big bang in the inflationary
Multiverse there could be parallel
universes each experiencing their own
big bangs and crunches then in the
conformal cylic cosmology Triple C it
can also have an infinite number of
effectively infinite number of big BS so
all these four models there's not a
single Big B that's the answer of my
question at the pose in the title the
top so how do you how do you even
proceed in such a situation well popper
gave us kind of a a rubric that you
could pursue that you should scrutinize
experiments scrutinize theories rather
uh with so-called decisive experiment so
what's an decisive experiment it's an
experiment that can be falsified now
Paul will tell you and I will tell you
that poer is not we don't look the poer
we don't say oh something is falsifiable
therefore it's scientific because I can
falsify astrology can't I my astrologer
yesterday just told me I would have you
know that the uh earlier this year said
the padr would be in the World Series
instead of your beautiful Diamond bags
and that didn't happen so that therefore
her prediction was falsified therefore
astrology is science that's nonsense but
we can use that as a rubric to test for
new physics that would be indicative of
alternative models happens to be when I
study is called B mode polarization and
it is the decisive experiment it's an
animation from Wayne Hugh my friend at
you Chicago shows different types of
pertubations I just want to draw your
eye to the lower right this shows a s
ated image it actually is a real data
set and I'll explain why I tricked you
for a second but it shows what you would
see if you had microwave eyes looking
through a refracting telescope like this
if you can see me and you had a
polarizer on it and you just measured
instead of the temperature of the sky as
a function of position you measured its
polarization and you decomposed it into
so-called B modes if there were
gravitational waves they would produce a
pattern like this and if those
gravitational waves were found to exist
all over the universe they would be a
background like the CNB therefore they'd
be fossils from an early time in the
universe and in fact those fossils
travel at the speed of light just like
light and they would be indicative of
this Bunch Davy state or this
inflationary State those perations in a
different characteristic that Paul and
his colleagues studied many many decades
ago and in fact we did measure this we
actually measure these inflationary
gravitational waves and the kicker that
you should be keeping in the back of
your mind is that if inflation took
place there is a
Multiverse that you exist along with an
infinite number of other copies of you
in what's called a Multiverse universe
is within the Multiverse I don't have
time to get into it uh but we'll talk
about it uh maybe in the Q&A so we did
this with an experiment that I created
when I was a postto at Caltech 23 years
ago called bicep which later became
bicep 2 it's a simple Galilean
refracting telescope instead of being in
Padua or Northern Italy uh we took this
instrument and and its tripod uh down to
the South Pole the very bottom of the
world and after uh three years of OBS
observation we indeed measured this
twirling twisting curling pattern of
microid polarization called bod
polarization and it made headlines all
around the world and this is in uh
2014 and so now I tell you this is
actually the real data and this set off
a a flood of attention of um claims of
Nobel prizes in the offing you know
spoiler alert I did not win one that's
why my book is losing the Nobel Prize
but there you see the paper of record on
the left there the Union Tribune uh with
me gazing up and some number of zeros
and seconds after the big bang and then
yeah there's this paper in New York The
Economist did a story about it the onion
did a story about it uh CNN covered it
live uh from the South Pole in Harvard
where the Press Conference was held it
was uh if you remember it and you old
enough to remember it you remember it
was indeed H was one of the greatest
measurements of all time including by
the then director of the be the origin
Center there uh Professor Lawrence
Krauss who just came to San Diego
recently and we did a live event
together last week in fact at the San
Diego Aaron Space Museum and I gave him
a little bit of grief for some of the
claims that he made back then uh but
hidden and lurking always was this
notion that we may have made a mistake
and in fact it turned out that the claim
that we detected inflationary
gravitational WS themselves a harbinger
of the inflationary Epoch itself the
imprator perhaps of the Multiverse was
actually colored pixelated by an
imprator that wasn't what we saw it was
an impostor signal it was Interstellar
dust and so after about six or seven
months we worked with our competitors
really the plank
telescope they had data that we lacked
when we announced that in March and by
December and January of the following
year we had verified that what we had
seen was not at all twisting
polarization caused by gravitational
waves caused by inflation but instead
the alignment of microscopic dust
molecules lined up by the Milky Ways
magnetic field and so at that point we
resolved we have to do better the
universe isn't this
pristine U cartoon diagram instead it's
a pretty smoggy place like Los Angeles
that um is pretty polluted and the only
way to get rid of this pollution is not
you know to move to a different galaxy
it's to measure at multiple frequencies
and the bicep team is now doing this we
are also doing this with the $110
million Simon Observatory funded by the
Simons Foundation Jim and Maryland
Simons there heising Simons foundation
and many of our partner institutions I
see Arizona State's logo in the lower
left there I can recognize it anywhere
and uh it's a huge profit 3 180 people
about 200 came last year to our group
Face Toof face meeting at UCSD we have a
a very very very active uh uh set of
instruments that I'll describe to you
and we recently got our first data I
hesitate to call it first light because
first light you could almost think we're
gonna start doing uh the the science of
looking for B mods that's not really
what we're doing at the very moment but
instead from this site not at the south
pole but in Chile at 177,000 FT we're
measuring with the instruments so on the
bottom you see a rendering artist
rendering or graphic uh rendering on the
top you see the actual layout it's a
different orientation might be a little
confusing but this was taken a couple
weeks ago on top so we've turned solid
works into reality and it's quite
astounding so we have three refracting
telescopes just like the bicep
telescopes in many ways but much more
sensitive many more detectors built by
Suzanne Stags at prinston and her team
at Nest um and others at nist with a lot
of help from Phil moff and Sean Bryan
other people at ASU and then we have a
giant telescope that's 5 meters six
meters in diameter in a building that
you saw and again let's get back to the
stakes of what we're doing we're looking
for the B mode signal we know that there
are B modes from dust we don't know if
there are B modes from inflation but if
we detect B modes and we prove
conclusively they're not dust then we
will have falsified the Quasi steady
state model The Bouncing model the uh
and the conformal cyclic model for
example we can't falsify or prove
inflation but we can give a lot of
circumstantial evidence on top of the
already existing mountain of evidence
that some say but others don't and just
to again remind you of the stakes there
are two gentlemen associated with the um
uh with the inflationary Paradigm Andre
Lind was on my podcast and we spoke for
three hours this year about the
Multiverse and its discontent so look
for that podcast if you're interested
and Andre's perspective as fascinating
as always and then uh I like to remind
people of the the Mastadon in the room
is the Multiverse and its implications
for the very beginning of this talk he
talked about the philosophy the ontology
of cosmology and why it's so important
to people and why people care about
Origins so much and as Paul said so so
brilliantly um he said that the
Multiverse has almost theological
overtones to it uh and so to explain
what we see in the universe mean uh
often invokes uh unseen forces just like
a creation narrative might be from a
Biblical perspective so it may be
dressed up Paul says in scientific
language but it requires the same leap
of faith so I find that fascinating it
gives me energy and encouragement to
pursue this most oldest perhaps of human
Endeavors to understand why we exist
where we came from and maybe just maybe
where things will go in the
future and for right now uh I invite you
to take a QR code again of both of these
but if you go on the left I'm kind of
curious about what you're most
interested about in cosmology in space
and at astronomy and so I set up this QR
code to do a survey tonight um and so
hopefully it'll work I'm going to try it
on my phone right now uh it should work
and you'll be whisked away to a survey
that you can fill out and tell me what
do you think is the most interesting
perhaps uh thing to study in space it
could be aliens it could be planets
anything beyond our own home surface of
our planet so I thank you very much and
believe I will now take questions that
was so wonderful Brian um and for me
like a trip down memory lane and I have
to tell you that I always speak up for
fright H he gave me my first job in in
Cambridge in 1970 would you believe and
at that time uh the steady state theory
was in full of retreat nikar was his
postto down the corridor uh and they
were trying to sort of fix up uh the
steady state Theory with the with these
cycles that you mentioned and uh the
their detractors here well the the great
uh advantage of the steady state theory
was in they very precise predictions
that the Universe would look the same on
a large scale from EPO to EPO so it's
highly
falsifiable and of course once you start
adding more parameters then that
Criterion of Poa uh yeah you get into
into trouble because had enough
parameters they couldn't uh get away
with anything um however I I should say
that I think it's really important in
cosmology where that there should be
alternative models because then that
motivates the uh search for tests and uh
and also the the terrible problem of
bandwagoning that you get inevit inside
so Gets behind uh the fa favorite idea
and it's it's really important for uh to
have some alternative to to put up
against it you explained that very well
a healthy Marketplace of ideas when
there's not a monopoly right so now just
you know coming to your own work and the
uh polarization pattern and so on uh
when do you think well first of all do
you think it is going to be possible to
basically subtract the effect of the
foreground dust and see if there is a
residual that is left over from the big
Bank do you think that is possible and
if so when are we going to know the else
yeah so the bicep team which I'm I'm no
longer officially a member of even yeah
although I started off the experiment um
we parted ways and and that's fine but
uh they've gone much deeper in a series
of new experiments from bicep 2 to bicep
3 and now it's called bicep array where
they're also using multifrequency
channnel as we are to the only way to
get rid of a systematic in science if
you're measuring something on a balanc
scale and someone's putting their thumb
on it you have to do another measurement
that could be your eye could be another
scale or what have you you you have to
dedicate an entire new experiment to get
rid of that or remove it by going
outside the Galaxy you know even Jim
Simons won't fund that so the question
that we have is is can we do it using
modeling and the bicep team have gotten
uh quite good at this with with Warn and
data from their own data set rather than
relying on the plank data which are not
as sensitive now for the first time the
question is yes we can remove it we've
already removed a lot of foregrounds for
many of our experiments including dust
but the question is what level of
ultimate sensitivity remains as you know
when you have a foreground like dust you
measure the combined you know Cosmic
signal C plus the dust signal D and then
you dedicate another experiment to
measure D and then you subtract
measurement one you subtract measurement
two from measurement one you subract D
from C plus d you're left with C but
that c term also has extra noise so the
question is will that noise level swamp
the underlying inflationary signal well
then you have to tell me which one of
the 10,000 different models of inflation
you you choose it there seems to be a
consensus that there's a lot of momentum
for for a specific Target in in these
tensor pertubations that I talked about
uh that correspond to Bunch St these
effects right uh and those are
corresponding to a noise level that we
on the Simons Observatory could get to
with a three standard deviation
detection significance that's r001 for
the you know fishing Autos out there so
yeah it's it's a good question the
answer is we don't know because nobody
knows what level inflation took place at
or if inflation took place at all right
and and and seeing because you were kind
enough to mention the bunch Davies
vacuum a few times I always feel I
should tell people whatever happened to
Timber so he he was my PhD student in
the 1970s I was in ke's college in
London and the reason we did that work
was because if you have a a PhD student
but D need to tell you you need to give
them something that is doable if it's
impossible that they don't get that PhD
but nobody's done before and Quantum
field theory in curve background space
times as a a challenge mathematically
but the there's one space time that
works really well it's the c space
exponentially expanding universe and so
it was to give Tim his PhD he
successfully completed that and we
published a few papers and then he went
off into the world of business and uh I
think he's still unaware he's a cosmic
celebrity this was a long time ago and
so this piece of work has endured for
many decades really so I that's all I
wanted to say I think perhaps we should
move to the uh audience questions yes um
so yeah I also want to add one more
thing which is that my job before I came
to ASU was at auka which was The
Institute founded by giant narar so I
also have a connection to study State
model uh we have a lot of questions so
let's uh uh get into those um the first
uh there are many questions about
alternatives to the big bang and so
forth but I think the one of the first
things that maybe we you can start with
just as a uh to clarify what is meant by
the Multiverse there's a question from
Karen Hastings that says can you explain
what kind of Multiverse is implied by
inflation is this the same as the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics and then again uh later on
there's a question about whether the
Multiverse has the same timeline as we
do on Earth which which is sort of you
know in the in the U Marvel Cinematic
Universe you have lots of uh Multiverse
uh ideas floating around and those are
more like the the many worlds
interpretation so maybe can uh just
explain the um distinction yeah that's a
great question so um the answer is that
according to my friend and uh and and
colleague co-author Max tegar there are
four different types of
multivers and they range from you know
simple so-called uh Beyond the Horizon
type scenarios where we really know we
can't access regions of uh Earth's
surface uh just by looking at them
because there are things that are are
bent away by the curvature of the
two-dimensional surface of the Earth and
so they still exist but we can't really
determine directly of in further
existence using light because we can't
see them but if a boat is off the coast
of San Diego uh and it's Beyond the
Horizon it will make waves and just like
waves of gravity are not uh the same
characteristics they carry different
information than waves of light they
will convey information about the
existence of things beyond our Horizon
so that's sort of the first level of the
Multiverse there's Sim laws and
constants there may be other universes
literally there could be another
Universe in the vast space of the
Multiverse which is one you know a light
day in some abstract space which I'm not
going to Define precisely but that we in
other words find out about tomorrow
there are proposals of the way that you
could discern and perceive and infer the
existence of Another Universe through
the pattern observable of the CNB we
haven't seen it yet but that doesn't
mean that tomorrow we couldn't sort of
bump in to the universe next door as I
think Philip dick used to say then there
are of course uh the many worlds
interpretation that's in his uh
nomenclature third level three
Multiverse um I skipped over a couple
I'm not going to get into all those but
that's a timeline kind of Separation
this is a a um a cartoon I I believe
made by my late colleague Andy fredman
who Al supplied it to Max tegar and it
shows the shringer cat experiment famous
where you have a superposition hybrid of
a cat that's alive and dead in the
Copenhagen interpretation but no such
minations are needed in the many worlds
hypothesis because the universal wave
function is branching at a rate of 10
the minus 36 seconds or so well beyond
what we could ever hope to imagine to to
observe and all the cat is alive in one
universe and dead in the other one or
you know uh and so that's a that's a
different form of the
Multiverse and there are claims that I
don't know you guys am Malik and and and
Paul could speculate and join in on this
but you know there are claims that there
are certain you know quantum mechanical
manifestations of this that are
observable you know manifestations from
the double slit experiment famous young
double slit experiment or you know
quantum computers uh they're not really
so definitively proven or or motivated
in my mind uh but that doesn't stop
people like mff Max from speculating and
in fact in the ultimate instantiation of
the Multiverse really the only thing
that that exist is mathematics and that
all different uh aspects of mathematical
equations and constants and so forth can
ex that can exist do exist in the level
four Multiverse very highly speculative
you know just because as Fineman used to
say you can give something a name
doesn't mean you understand it hey there
it's me again Professor Brian keing here
with a special offer do you want to join
our Cosmic Quest and immerse yourself in
wisdom shared by Nobel laurates
billionaires astronauts award-winning
authors and masters of time and space
then you join my Monday magic mailing
list I send out a bit of wisdom each
Monday just five items the most
interesting topics from the world of
space and beyond our universe I think
you'll enjoy it and it's free as a token
of my appreciation I also pick one of
you each month to win a free chunk of
meteorite a real 4.3 billion year old
fragment of our solar systems earliest
moments so join us on this Quest
subscribe today briank king.com now back
to the episode uh there are also
questions about uh uh alternatives to
the Big Bang so uh particular what seems
to be the strongest candidates for the
epoch before the Big Bang if such any
Pock this is a question from Richard
Hart sent by email yeah so if there was
a big bang uh or is some origin to our
universe then it makes perfect sense to
ask you know what happened on the
Tuesday before our big bang in our
universe I I personally think the best
way to think about the Big Bang is
extrapolating from the laws of physics
we know and love and understand today
when do we go in backwards fashion going
backwards in time when do we lose
connection and contact with physics that
we can make predictive uh statements
about and for most people I would say
that that goes back from today you know
on October 30th 2023 back 13.8 billion
years uh up to about a microsecond or
maybe a nanosecond uh and and then if
you go another try to go anytime before
that nanc after whatever either the
origin of current Universe the origin of
time we really have no idea what there
could be so all these things are are
possible I would say they have varying
degrees of credulity to them the
bouncing model has a lot more work on it
than the conformal cyclic model of Sir
Roger Penrose he's really one of the few
people that's truly working on it and of
course you know he's a noble laured so
he gets a lot of attention and
deservedly so he's a brilliant and
creative individual doesn't mean he's
right um what I have to kind of think
about is what would be my dream what
would be a dream scenario for a
explanation for
cosmogenesis uh what would it what
features would it possess and one of
those features that I'd like it to
possess is the absence of an unknown
unmeasurable scalar field what's called
a scalar field which in the case of
inflation is called the inflaton uh in
the case of uh The Bouncing model there
there are certain fields that that
behave and uh as a curvature in in a
Quantum scalar field that's they just
posit that in the Quasi steady state
model they actually had something that
was like dark energy except they evolved
what we call quintessence nowadays uh
and that was called the sea or creation
field so all these things have that flaw
so that's why I put yes in red because I
don't like it uh and actually Roger
penoses doesn't have a scalar field but
it has these weird things called arabon
which is a form of dark matter which he
calls you know strangely diffusing so
I'm yet I'm I'm highly dissatisfied by E
theorist I I think you guys should be
ashamed no I I I I I love to think about
these things but in my mind you'd like
to explain you know the origin of the
universe in terms of things that we know
and love uh like actual fonic Fields
bosonic fields and there is a scalar
field we know called the higs field and
people have posited a connection between
the higs field and inflation uh my past
guest recently Katie Freeze is was one
among them so uh I think that the the
most uh precise way an experimentalist
like me should go about is completely
dispassionate and if we do observe it uh
a gravitational wave signature then that
will rule out they that by all their
admissions conformal cyclic quasy steady
state balancing model they all say no if
You observe that that will falsify my
model and that's as good as we can get
and then if we do measure an actual
tensor power Spectrum we can then probe
the Dynamics of how inflation took place
so that'd be incredibly exciting will it
happen we don't know that's why it's
called research um okay here's a
question from Barbara Temple also sent
in by email um how can theories where
the universe isn't expanding work when
we observe red shift in almost all
galaxies well there are all these
theories have expanding universes so
even this one the Quasi steady state
model can you see that this model has uh
changes in the distance between galaxies
I didn't label the time axis but but if
I did it would be in you know each cycle
last a trillion years so it's just like
looking at a ball if you see a baseball
hit tonight
by no I'm trying I only can remember
people that used to be on the diamond
packs who's your number one power
Slugger Malik help me out Paul asking
the wrong
people
me so you see some guy I was going to
say Paul goldi but that's probably not
good uh and you see a ball and he hit it
up and it's going up that's doesn't tell
you anything about what its ultimate
fate is right it could be going at at 8
miles per second and escape the Earth
completely or it could be going at you
know one or two miles per hour and you
just wouldn't know it from a single
snapshot effectively out a trillion
years we've only been making these
observations and and able to Glimpse you
know billions of year time scales which
sounds like a lot to humans but compared
to trillions it's it's almost infinite
intestinal so there's not there's no way
to tell but in all these models there's
expanding dynamical universe except
sometimes it collapses which the Big
Bang model doesn't so if there was
evidence for a collapse of a universe
that you discovered independently of
these B modes and yes you could sort of
be able to rule out some of these models
versus the expanding Big Bang model but
well from time to time you uh I
certainly and you probably get uh
manuscripts and uh email messages from
people say I don't believe the universe
is expanding what about the tired light
hypothesis suddenly red shift that we
use to measure the expansion universes
because light gets weaker over
time Andy you've heard a lot of doesn't
go away yeah you've heard a lot about
that recently with the James web Space
Telescope results that seem to indicate
that these galaxies are will mature
their spirals they're spinning they're
doing all their things only 390 million
years after the big bang and this you
know is an athema to people that I've
debated on my YouTube channel and will
continue to debate um and uh and and
these are very interesting conjectures
but things tired light and and so forth
you have to ask what C compromises do
their equation do their uh New
Alternatives to the Big Bang they say
some say the Big Bang never happened
some say the universe is twice as old as
we thought it was and I I got into this
debate when I had the opportunity to go
on Joe Rogan's podcast that you know
there is this you know basically meme
almost that went around the world that
attracted his attention and Elon Musk
and every but oh the universe is 26
billion well like like 13 billion isn't
large enough you know like oh that's
that's we can explain that easily so the
question is you know what is the most
economical explanation for the data
points that experimentalists and
observers like my colleagues are making
how how can you explain them most
economically given a paradigm which is
necessarily going to be wrong at some
level and the question is how many
predictions does it attribute correctly
to and how many obser observables agree
with the overarching paradigm so far the
Big Bang model again Big Bang is taken
to mean many things so when I say the
Big Bang model passes these tests you
have to ask me what version of it and
that's fair but you the version in which
we synthesize Light Elements a microsc
or two after the formation of at least
our observable universe and that lasts
for 20 minutes or so you know shorter
than an episode of The Big Bang Theory
makes all the hydrogen effectively
tridium uterum lithium brillium Etc and
then nothing else happens for couple
hundred billion years it's how large
Stars start to form um Supernova that
make the elements and the heavier
elements in the periodic table that
Burbage and Burbage and hoil and and
Fowler studied in their famous paper you
know 70 plus years ago so it's exciting
but yeah we get I get these emails all
the time except they usually say I'm not
good at math professor keig I say don't
tell me about your math problems though
was an old Einstein joke um okay so
here's a question from Mark lenis which
uh I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly
which is related to the cyclic uh models
what happens to the entropy of the
universe the entropy supposed to go up
and so how can it be that the Universe
both expands and contracts yeah it's so
funny this uh scientist named Tolman had
so many of these ideas back in the 30s
and 40s the collapsing model of the
universe and then he would like refute
that uh he also came up with the
reputation of the tired light model he
also uh came up despite the fact that
even in addition to the fact that he
realized there was no mechanism by which
photons could lose mass energy we don't
see them losing energy on you know
scales of the size of our galaxy um so
he he explained his own you know he came
over the theory he refuted it so he's an
astounding scientist I I really have a
lot of respect for him um so yes so he
pointed out that in a collapsing model
you'd have this problem of entropy and
that resuscitated itself though although
you wouldn't think it in my mind Paul
tell me if you agree I mean the
inflation model just a standard infl
model is the closest to kind of the
singularity Big Bang model you know
there's an origin point and bunch Davies
State you know pred but then you have
this big bang like moment but it
involves some Quantum gravitational
aspects correct yeah yes and I was going
to raise myself the problem of the arrow
of time because if the intervals has
always existed there's the problem that
why hasn't reached its asmic end state
by now state of Maximum entropy uh how
can it be re juvenated uh and I think
all of the models whether they're cyclic
or there just one bounce uh really
suffer from that problem and the only
model that I know that really escapes it
uh was the model that fren H cooked up
uh after the original steady state
Theory and I should just mention in
passing he was the one who coined the
term Bean bang that's he didn't believe
the big bag model and it was a term of
derision but he had some model uh in
which the
universe conics for every nebor and goes
through some minimum phase and then
expands for every lever uh but uh it's
it's basically the steady state theory
in the far future and in the far past
but in a Time reverse set so it's
overall time symmetric matter has
created uh One Wing of this U uh and uh
it's reversed in the other wing and an
arbitary observer will be L away from
the turning point would think that they
would live in a steady state Theory and
so there's no problem there with the
arrow of time it's overall time
symmetric but in all the other models
that I know uh there's some sort of
fudge that takes place but you're quite
right that the expansion the inflation
what that does for you it um Smooths
everything out and therefore from the
gravitational point of view that's a low
entropy State and that uh sets the the
great Cosmic clock going and
and the Ed subsequently Rises but you
can still wonder about the ultimate
origin of this hour time of what what
why it is that the Universe started out
uh in the right condition to produce
inflation you really moving the bump in
the carpet all the time we're
unfortunately we're almost out of time
so I'm GNA have leave you with one last
question this is from Ethan fam who's in
my class uh if there was another big
bang uh would the physics of the
universe that comes after be the same as
the physics we have now the answer of
course you know many of these things is
we don't know and that's the best answer
a scientist can give when he or she is
uncertain uh but I I would say that uh
it's a great question in many fronts it
prompts a question that I've had for a
long time which is you know why is it
only that in certain models of the of
the Multiverse that you get changes to
the laws of physics why wouldn't there
be modifications to the laws of
mathematics why wouldn't you get modus
tolin and modus ponin they would be
differing so that you know if a then B
and you have a not b or so you know
there could be crazy things and and we
abstract so much to these Notions of
what's called hird space and then we
just assume that Constance and so forth
are are finally tuned or matched to the
specific physics that we observe but we
have no idea and so it's um it's not an
all clear that we would have the same
laws of physics or even the same
physical constants and there are models
in Paul and and Malika sure based on
your research you could you could
probably name a couple different things
motivated from string theoretic or uh M
Theory Etc where you could get different
constants at least if not different laws
of of physics from the different vacua
that stream theory predicts in the
so-called landscape which is its own
form of Multiverse I think of it but
correct me if I'm wrong so I I think
it's a fascinating question Ethan I we
don't know um and it's not even clear
that measuring the B mods that you know
sorry to disappoint you but let's say we
do do it and you know I finally win my
Nobel Prize I'm so desperate according
to the internet to win but you know that
wouldn't necessarily answer wouldn't
prove that the Multiverse exists either
it would kind of be like I I liken it to
well we would describe that we live some
as if we're bacteria we're in a culture
in a dish a petri dish and there could
be other petri dish you know dishes and
there could be other colonies within our
own petri dish but the chemical speed of
communication between those colonies is
so slow that we would never find out
about them but we know that there's this
agar gel that we're sitting on top of so
that at least the potential for other
bacteriological cultures exist and so
that tortured analogy kind of is the
only way I can think that discovering
inflation means the Multiverse is
motivated um but again it wouldn't be
proof it wouldn't be rise the level of
observational proof that even detecting
gravitational wave bods would then
inflation took place so it's it's kind
of an overburden situation but I I find
it the most fascinating thing you could
possibly study so for me you know Count
Me In anything that it could do uh you
know to describe laws of physics or
nature the better so um really
appreciate the question thank you Brian
and also Paul thank you guys